- I descend from the sky and
land on things really hard
and I go at everything
with that amount of fury.
Every damn person who said
I wouldn't be anything,
I'm crushing them every day.
What are you doing tomorrow?
Eight o'clock on stage.
What are you doing the night after?
I'll be on stage.
What about two months from now?
I'll be still on that same tour.
- He's an American musician,
actor, writer, and comedian.
He fronted the hardcore
California punk band Black Flag.
He hosts a weekly radio show
and is a regular columnist for LA Weekly.
He's Henry Rollins and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best
and as always guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well.
Also as you are writing something down,
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- You once said in an
interview that your life
is paranoia and fear and you're
just trying to not get hit.
- Yeah.
- Is that still true?
Anger and fear, fear of failure drives me.
Paranoia of things going
wrong around me drives me.
I am driven by a lot of like
really kind of ugly anger,
and so I have a lot of that in me,
and it comes from a
father who was terrifying
and teachers who yelled at me,
told me I'd never be anything
and so I descend from the sky
and land on things really hard
and I go at everything
with that amount of fury,
and I'm not saying I'm
going to hit anybody,
and I'm not mad at you.
I'm quite happy to be here with you
and answer any question
to the best of my ability,
but I go at everything
like you think I can't.
Hey, you want to try acting?
Yeah, I'll try acting.
Can you act?
No, so let's go.
- I've seen Sons of Anarchy, you can act.
- Thank you.
Fair is for losers.
I'd rather win.
- You tend to be incredibly
modest in terms of
describing your talents, and
you always seem to belittle
your abilities to a certain extent
when clearly there's a reason why this,
everything you do's been working out.
I was reading about how you
said that to a certain extent
that comes from your punk rock roots.
- Yeah, there was no other choice.
In those days, there was no
idea of this makes money.
There's no idea of like this is my future.
It was like a week at a time.
We have five shows, we're
going to get to Sunday. Phew.
And even those days were
like fraught with turbulence.
And so I never really saw a future.
None of us did, and some
of us didn't make it.
Some of them are dead,
and some of them are just
kind of trying to recreate
their past, and so
I realized that I have
to be very hard working
because I don't have kind
of the ease of talent,
and I come from that, and
I think in a lot of ways,
it's served me very well in that I am
kind of as hard working as I've ever been
completely without confidence.
I have none.
I don't want any.
Because I think you turn
your back on the thing,
and that's when you get gored,
is when you think, "I got this."
I never think, "I got this."
I think, "Oh, man, don't screw this up."
And I go at everything like including
you and I sitting here right now.
I'm trying to be fully engaged,
and that intensity, I think has served me
quite well, but it comes
from punk rock, absolutely.
Last boss I ever had was
my boss at Haagen-Dazs
at my ice cream shop, and
to this day, he still comes
to my shows, and whenever I see Steve,
who got me my first
apartment, who believed.
I was living in my car.
He believed in me.
Whenever I see him, I get all weepy.
I always sound like, "It's
good to see you sir."
"Henry, you can call me Steve."
"I can't do that, sir."
'Cause he trusted me with his money,
and I said, "Let me run your store.
"I know how to do this, I can do this."
He's like, "Well, if you
screw up, you're out of here."
I said, "I won't screw
up," and it ended up being,
I ran his store, and so,
but it was anger that said,
"I'll be here all damn week.
"I'll get this whole thing right."
I fired a staff and rehired a bunch
of people, who can really work,
and it was, out of anger, like
"I'll be back in four hours
"to run this $3.75 an
hour job into the ground."
And then I joined Black Flag, and I
thought I was a hard-working person.
Then you meet the guys in
Black Flag, who are so driven.
You see Greg Ginn work 23 hour days.
Like, "Greg, you're still on the phone."
"I know."
"Greg, when did you eat?"
"I don't know."
"Greg, when was the
last time you showered?"
"Uh, do we have a shower?"
Like the guy was, we were
not going to be stopped,
and I kind of go at that intensity
like kind of anything I do.
Like you're a very calm,
good-looking young man.
Look at me, I'm a spaz sitting next to you
like, "I'm doing an interview with you."
I can't help it.
- Focused.
- I'm sweating, man.
It's so.
(laughter)
But I'm like this going
to the airport like.
10 miles out.
And so, but it's anger that
has informed kind of my life,
and unflatteringly a sense of vengeance.
Every damn person who said
I wouldn't be anything,
I'm crushing them every day.
Everybody I had to endure
in any band I was in,
every day into a powder.
Yeah.
(applause)
- Thank you.
And I wish them no ill.
I just wish to shine brighter,
and if it burns my body to a crisp,
I'm happy to go right now.
I just do my work.
For me, I've always been
very utilitarian on all
of this stuff, and that's what
coming from punk rock gave to me.
Well I don't feel like I'm anybody,
and someone wants me to sign
something, I'm like, "Sure."
I don't exactly understand
why, but I'll do it for you.
I don't think I'm anything.
- Maybe it's also, not just because
of the punk rock mentality.
It's also because you were scooping
ice cream not so long ago,
and maybe there's an element
of insecurity in you that
unless you keep working and keep striving,
you could end up back there.
- Oh I kind of figure that's eventual.
I keep moving forward boldly
because I have nothing to lose.
I'm nobody from nowhere.
You should really understand that.
I am from the minimum wage working world
a hundred years ago, but I
don't ever have it in my head
that that's any less, any
more than one tour away
of coming back, and so
I just, I like to work.
It's not a money or fame or anything.
It's about activity and challenge.
I was a very
headstrong young person, and by
1983 or four
had started my own
publishing company to publish
my own books, realizing that
no one else'll publish me,
and I was right about that,
and so my first book,
I saved my food money
from Black Flag, a little
here, little there,
and I saved enough to make
a fold and staple book.
I couldn't type, so I
handwrote out the things,
and I made a dummy that I could
offset, print, fold and staple.
And I sold them for $2,
mainly gave them away,
but I sold enough, and they blew out,
500 just went, and then I took that money
to make another print run of that,
and from that money, I
made my first paperback,
and 33 years later,
that's a fully staffed company
with books in translation
and hardcover editions
and the whole, you know
the whole nine yards,
but it started with, I'm
going to do my thing.
I'll be City Lights
Junior without the talent,
and that's
I did that at the same
time I was doing my first
spoken word gigs, and why
did I have the gumption
and the audacity to start
my own book company?
Because I come from punk rock.
I come from watching Ian MacKaye
invent Dischord Records on
his mom's kitchen table.
I come from folding and gluing
picture sleeves together.
Black Flag had their own label.
Of course you do it yourself.
You want to make a book,
sit down and write it,
then go to the printing place.
Where's a printer?
Get in the phone book and find a printer.
We make records, make some books.
It was, you just do it.
It's like you don't even think about it.
You just do it, and I'm sure that
writing is just awful, but I did it,
and without even hesitation
I'm making my own book company.
Stop me. I dare you.
I never thought about it twice.
Just because DIY man, like
let your voice be heard.
My last straight job I had was 1981.
Head manager of a
Haagen-Dazs in Georgetown,
in Washington, D.C. on Wisconsin
Avenue at the intersection
of Wisconsin and O Street,
making $3.75 an hour, $4 an hour,
something like that, working
40 to 60 hours a week.
I had a small apartment, which I
shared with an old pal of mine.
I had a small record collection,
an ailing VW automobile,
and a little tiny life
with my minimum wage job,
which I liked, and I looked
at my life and realized,
this is probably about as good
as it's going to get for me.
I might quit this place
and go work at my friend's
record store 'cause I
liked being around records,
and I could probably
run his store very well,
knowing what I knew about
retail at that point,
and then I got a very lucky break
'cause at that same time,
I was very frustrated.
I said, "Well, this is going
to be a very tough life.
"It's going to be a life of
a lot of standing on my feet,
"a lot of work, taking
it from other people,
"and having very little to show
for it by Friday, you know,
"Friday evening," and then Black Flag,
the famous band who was friends
of mine, they played in New York.
I was in Washington, I took
a ride up to go see them
'cause they weren't
coming down to my town.
I jumped on stage and
sang with them that night
a song 'cause I had to
go back down to D.C.
and go work like some awful shift.
They called me a few days
later at the ice cream store
and said, "You know, we're
looking for a singer,"
'cause the rhythm guitar player wants to,
oh I'm sorry, the vocalist wants
to move down to rhythm guitar.
You can tell I've told this story before.
And we're holding auditions,
do you want a crack at this
'cause we saw you onstage the other night.
You're pretty wild.
I looked at the ice
cream scoop in my hand,
my chocolate bespattered apron,
and my future in the world
of minimum wage work,
or I could go up to New
York and audition for this
crazy band who was my favorite.
What's the worse that's
going to happen to me?
I miss a day of work,
oh, there goes 21 bucks,
and I get humiliated in
front of my favorite band.
Humiliation in young
people kind of go together.
I was used to it, and so
I took a train up there,
I walked into this practice
place in the east village.
I'm standing there with the band
with a microphone in my hand.
They said, "Pick the tune,"
and I sang every song they had,
you know, improvising most of it.
Two times through we did the set.
They said, "Okay, you have a seat.
"We're going to go have a band
meeting," whatever that means.
And they came back like 10 minutes
later and said, "Okay, you're in."
I said, "What do you mean?"
They said, "You're the
singer in Black Flag."
I said, "So what do I do?"
They go, "You quit your
job, you pack your gear,
"you meet us on the road.
"Here's the tour itinerary.
"Here's the lyrics. We'll see you soon."
So fairly numb, I went
back down to Washington
with this passel of lyrics in my hand,
went to my boss and said,
"Uh, I'm not exactly quitting,
"but here's this thing that happened."
He said, "It's your shot."
I said, "Yeah."
He said, "Take it."
I feel a genuine need to
communicate with an audience,
and it might just be the
attention I didn't get as a kid.
It can't come from anything good,
but what I try and do is
bring the best information
I can to the stage and broadcast it,
so I'm, it's repoirtage
from distant points from
a fairly unique standpoint,
and so basically
I'm not keeping it all to
myself, but I earnestly try to,
it's not about entertainment.
It's about communication,
warning, broadcasting,
emitting, and trying to leave something
of myself with these, with the audience.
It's not mere entertainment.
It's not just making people laugh or not.
It's got to hurt me.
It's got to leave lines in my face.
I don't like any artistic endeavor
that doesn't extol a
price on the one doing it.
So I'm not looking to get
through these things okay.
These things are actually very difficult
and very hard on my psyche, which makes
me think I'm doing the right thing.
Guys like me have to do everything
three times before we get it right.
Thankfully I know that,
so I know that I have to
get up early and try it five times because
the eight year old will be able to
get past it in two times, so I have to
be on my feet longer,
but at least I know it.
And so I just go at stuff,
and it's served me very well
in that my resume's pretty varied, and
I have a pretty interesting life.
I get to do different stuff
and have a bit of access
because I just say, "Yeah, I'll try that."
I mean, why would I hold back.
The repeating factors of my life have been
application, discipline,
focus, repetition,
you know, a gig, a gig, a gig.
What are you doing tomorrow?
Eight o'clock on stage.
What are you doing the night after?
I'll be on stage.
What about two months from now?
I'll be still on that same
tour 'cause I manage myself.
I know where I'm going.
I might not finish it.
I might not survive it,
but I'm the one bookin' it.
- Do you spend more time
thinking about the future
or the past?
- The future.
- Why is that?
- Because I want it, 'cause the past
holds all of your
mistakes and humiliations.
The future holds whatever you can make it,
and so the past is
already been determined,
and it also holds all your victories
and all your accomplishments, but all
the bad stuff is there too, so why dwell?
Learn from it and move on.
Don't ignore it, and don't
say it didn't happen.
Don't deny it,
but don't, you don't have to
dwell on it and be miserable.
That happens enough to us adults already.
You see someone from
your past, you're like,
"Oh, it still hurts,"
but the future's ready for you
to not make those mistakes,
and to make it great, and
now that I have less future
than I do past, I seek to
make, 'cause I'm well over
the 50 yard line of mortality.
(laugh)
I'm 55.
You know, there's no way
I'm getting 110 out of this.
- I don't know.
- You never know.
- You seem pretty energetic, I'm saying.
- Well it might just burn me out, but
knowing I have less in
front of me than behind me,
why not be cool with it?
Don't, I'm going to die soon, like look,
you got some time left, rock
out, like make it amazing,
where the past has been done.
♫ I can feel your love
♫ It's hard to be with you
♫ You're a liar liar
with your pants on fire
♫ Tearing myself apart
♫ Waiting on a full ride
♫ Your face
♫ Tearing myself apart
♫ So close, so close, not close enough
♫ Tearing each other apart
♫ When I see you
♫ I want to tell you
♫ But then I lose the words
♫ And it tears me apart
♫ Tearing me apart ♫ Tearing you apart
♫ Tearing us apart
♫ Yeah
♫ Better walk away
♫ Throw away
♫ And I've got a hole inside
♫ And I'll keep it deep inside
♫ And I'm cold, cold inside
♫ And it's there I'll blow a hide
♫ 'Cause I got to get away
♫ Trust me if I'm okay
♫ I've got to get away
♫ Trust me I'm okay
♫ Sometimes they fall without you
♫ And it tears me apart
♫ Tears me apart
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video
because Kurt asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Henry say
that had the biggest
impact on you and why.
What message did you take from him
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, wanted to give a quick
shout out to Rhonda Young.
Rhonda thank you so much for all
your support of my book, "Your One Word."
I really, really, really appreciate it.
(native music)
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- I sang with Dinosaur
Junior last December
because they asked me.
I did a song, "Don't,"
which only has, "Why?
Why don't you like me?"
so even I could get the lyric.
But I did it because Jay asked me,
and I don't want to disappoint those guys,
and I remember afterwards, they all came
up to me like, "That was really intense."
I'm like, "There's, what
other way do you do it?"
- Especially with those
guys with Dinosaur Junior.
- Oh it was, with Jay,
being onstage with Jay was,
which is all of them, but
that much guitar volume,
that was something else.
'Cause I'm a fan, big fan of that band,
but yeah all of that is still there,
but if you're not, if what
you're pushing forward
isn't all the way real, then
if it's 98% real, then the 2%
that you're lying to
the crowd, shame on you.
I can't do that.
This is hallowed ground for
me, and so if it's not 100%,
I sadly have to walk away.
- The reason I do what I do,
the reasons why I get to do what I do
all come from 1970 something
into 1981,
high school to me leaving,
punk rock, literature,
poetry, realizing the
power of putting the pen
to the paper and expressing yourself.
That if you can write, you can write.
Let's break that sentence
down for a minute.
If you can form a sentence,
you can form a sentence,
and it doesn't matter who you are.
It doesn't matter if you're
the high school quarterback,
going to be with the
pretty girl at the prom,
or if you're the loser, which you're not,
and the person who doesn't get picked
to be on the basketball team at gym,
you can write, and you
can have as much authority
over your own writing
as Flannery O'Connor,
Earnest Hemingway, or
anyone you can imagine.
You can have your own, and
you will find in your life
that some of the only real true freedom
you'll ever get is your imagination,
your thoughts, and what
you can put on the paper,
and the good news is you never, ever,
ever have to show it to anyone.
It can be like a meditation
that you can write to yourself.
You can be as angry as you want.
You can make up anything you want.
You are never freer than
when you're putting it down
and I always say pen and
paper because I have an analog
relationship with writing,
but if you want to key it in,
you can do that too, and
you can be a 53 year old
man like me and still do a
journal entry every day as I do
because it is part of my way
is to check in with myself.
Hey Henry, how you doing?
Well, I'm pretty sad
today because of this,
and I'm very angry about this.
There's a lot of writing I do
volumes of it that no one sees.
I never publish it.
I just need to check in with myself
through the hand, the ink to the paper,
and anyone can do that and
you never have to show it
to anyone, not your significant other,
not your brothers or sisters
or parents or teachers.
It can be exclusively yours.